every day there's more and more people
here and you've got to go farther and
farther out and then you find even more
people
and now there's not much places you know
around town to get out of the city life
it's sitting no matter where you go
[Music]
every time I'm going to town
past all these grocery stores and the
computer shop and the pizza store and
the pet shop if you live in town it's
going to be expensive I just don't like
depending on a store for everything
I mean there's a much better way to live
if you're scared or uncomfortable you
can't go to sleep and you're sitting in
your bed and you're thinking about your
happy place
I think about mine every day I can tell
you exactly where it is
I'm sitting in my bed in the cabin along
the Cosner
and it's raining and I can hear the rain
fall in the tin roof
and for me that's everything and
something about life literally coming
from the heavens and falling onto my
roof and going into my buckets
so calming
but there's still so much work to do
before we finally reach our happy place
[Music]
just feel it's really good to be packing
everything up and getting ready to go
out to the cabin so this is crunch time
we're just trying to get everything
slammed out we got a lot going on
Chris and Jesse Morse are about to begin
the 100 mile journey to escape their
busy Fairbanks City Life with only a few
hours until their Bush flight it's
critical they pack everything they'll
need to survive on their own during
Alaska's harshest winter conditions
I spent all night just packing and
getting worried about having everything
for the winter just couldn't sleep 60
days I need 60 breakfast I need 60
lunches I need 60 dinners lists upon
lists inside of lists
[Music]
we're just trying to wrap everything
together here at the house we've just
got a few hours left until we take off I
feel like everything's secure this life
is locked up
I'm ready to start the life in the woods
I love the self-sustained living being
the plumber and being the Carpenter and
being the mechanic all of those things
you have to do yourself
the town's four hours away Parts pieces
materials are four hours away
help is four hours away but you're very
rarely going to get help out here
[Music]
hi silver such a good boy Yep this is
really the reason we're all here we
raise and train the best sled dogs in
the world and race them competitively in
Thousand Mile races these dogs are super
valuable they're my best friends they're
my family
got all the Necessities for a good day
trip and if I have to
overnight you got to be prepared for
anything when you get out there even
though we got our first snow here we're
still in that in between season
[Applause]
with winter around the corner Brent sass
must take advantage of any opportunity
to train his sled dog team in order to
keep them in shape for the harsh months
ahead
so this is just a recon mission make
sure there's enough snow we should go
out there with a dog team but first he
must Scout their Seven Mile training
Trail by snow machine to make sure it's
safe for his dogs
being 150 miles out of Fairbanks we're
living in the middle of nowhere so you
leave this place and everything is more
dire out there on the trail the most
important thing is survival
yeah well
it's mostly Frozen
there's definitely some shelf ice over
there that could fall through and it
doesn't take much to get this snow
machine stuck
but when you add ice and freezing
temperatures and moving water together
there's always room for disaster
this maybe isn't the smartest idea
we have to be safe about it
but where there's a will there's a way
Drive harder and go farther and it's
kind of just the way of life that I love
about six inches of snow
definitely enough to do the dog team so
got these trees out of the way and uh
head back home and get a dog team
that was the goal I think we're gonna
accomplish it
we're gonna go for it
the cold really continually pushes you
to keep working and you're always trying
to reach maximum efficiency with
everything you do
so I mean just like which is like the
ultimate challenge
[Music]
tips you're gonna wait Bobby
so today I'm gonna try something new
capture some hairs with snares
get some better food for myself
I have trapped before but not with this
type of trap
it's just like a thin flexible wire
the idea is rabbit goes through
it cinches up
they say you have to be 10 smarter than
the thing to catch it see if I'm 10
smarter than a rabbit
for Alex javor securing fresh protein is
essential to his survival
with no meat in his freezer
Alex must rely on his hunting skills in
order to eat
things tend to get worse the worse they
get right
hungry or you get the worst decisions
you make
kind of compounds and becomes a downward
spiral
and it'll be a little less likely to get
food and eat
here's a good example of a rabbit
Highway you can see they've not just
one's been three years like some place
where they're they're regularly going
through
so I'm gonna put all my snares in this
small bubble there's a lot of Fallen
trees and stuff that makes a lot of
opportunities for me to place my snares
and to create my little funnels
influence where the hairs are going to
go and hopefully pass through my snares
this is kind of you know yeah just
carpet bombing if I had 500 more to put
out that's better chances of getting
rabbits
today the game is can we outsmart the
rabbits
my last one here tomorrow we'll go check
the traps and hopefully got some rabbits
once they started getting on these wild
rivers and canoes
and really pushing the limits of myself
and my equipment
I just began to realize that I am
different in a lot of ways
[Music]
I created this mold from scratch that's
a two-piece mold it looks like it might
be a boat but it's not the boat is built
inside this mold and it's it's what they
call a cold mold process I'm just doing
it the old-fashioned way laying it up by
hand
as a proud mcmack Indian Michael Manzo
lives by his ancestral Traditions
hunting and traveling by canoe
in order to travel further and faster
than he has with his 18-foot canoe Manzo
is going to build one four feet longer
to maximize efficiency when spring
arrives
building it's sort of self-taught I just
got to the point where I said hey you
know I could build a better canoe but
I've taken a traditional concept and
I've made it radical in the present day
with the highest end materials I can get
my hands on and these unique little
surface Drive engines and the fuel
economy that comes from them I will not
sacrifice durability and quality and I
just much prefer to do it myself
that gives me a lot of pride
[Music]
these are my resins the blue gives the
strength clear gives the flexibility
this is a secret recipe for building a
hall I wouldn't even tell my mother what
I use and I vary and change the
flexibility of my resins as I
progressively get Inward and that helps
it to be resilient during impacts
this is kind of hard work this boat
building it kind of humbles you you've
you've been doing so much physical labor
for so many hours that your mind is
completely clear you don't have any
stress at the end of the day of boat
building you are at peace
because it's a long day
and there's still a lot of work that
needs to be done
there's different and new challenges
that are going to come up every day that
I cannot plan for
well we're here
I can hear your chopper coming oh it's
windy
come on sweetie
going out to the cabin can be real hard
it's 100 air miles from the nearest city
we have friends that have aircraft one
of them is running back and forth on Via
helicopter to the Village of Tanana
which is right over the top of our cabin
so for just a few bucks in gas money
he's picking us up every time we go out
to the cabin my dad drives us to catch
the helicopter he raised me to live off
grid I spent a lot of time out there he
told me how proud he is of me for not
doing the normal thing
friends with helicopters
to be a windy flight
flying out into the middle of nowhere in
the bush you know sometimes people don't
come back from that it gets me kind of
nervous
I'll be so stoked when I get to the
cabin I know it's worrisome we'll get
out there I love you so much
catching the helicopter is always a
stressful time
helicopters scare the bejeebus out of me
holy smokes I'm like breathe out
this is so sketchy
the flights that I've had out to the
cabin just haven't been very good
I get so anxious and nervous I make
myself sick
[Music]
it's the same thing in the city
but being out at the cabin is where I
want to be that's that's where my heart
is
that's why I have to keep putting
myselves on these helicopters
that's the only way to get to the
cabinet
and it's so worth it
it's like nothing else that you've ever
seen
[Music]
better
ever a bird in a past life
cave dwelling animals
good dog
[Music]
we're about three minutes out
with familiar
yes
[Music]
this is a much more familiar Landing
yeah
feels good to be home
all right Jess we're here
we got a lot of work to do now
[Music]
all right
glass doors let's go
I'm kind of worried about getting to the
cabin it's been a little while since
we've been here one of the things that
cabins always run into are bears out
here they get into the cabin they tear
out insulation and just wreck shop
we're really isolated out here and if
something has drastically happened it's
going to be really tough
now all I can think about is getting to
the cabin fast as possible
oh sweet zip lines are still up
we've got big zip lines up across the
river instead of trying to get across
the river and falling into the water and
going under the ice zip lines are just a
less dangerous option for us
here we come
[Music]
the animals are at the absolute worst
out here right now I would not be
surprised if a bear day is living in the
cabin
foreign
we've got some heavy prints back here
yeah so that open the door you'll see it
right here
Seattle
's been walking and walking up and
walking out that way do you think it's a
bear or smaller
probably a bear
but I don't see any damage
oh man what is this gross
play squirrels they're the only ones who
are two and two those big buckets how's
it look in there take it in
you see the plastic in there
that's a winter Supply it's a constant
battle every time we get to the cabin no
no no I'm vomit if I look in there again
the mice and the squirrels are getting
into stuff and I'm seeing all of this my
species nasty gross nightmarish scenes
in here coffee filters are just damp
with pee ugh this is gross yes I mean
let's just take everything down wipe it
down put it back up
I haven't had a chance to unpack and
there's just so much more work to do we
just really gotta tough it out get it
cleaned up the best we can because come
to winter time small problems can lead
to big problems
[Music]
almost everything I do wins and failure
but you know usually I learn from it and
you know the 10th time around or
something then you're able to do it
pretty well
there's different ways to hunt for meat
and it's really important to maintain a
Marksmanship
so this morning I'm gonna do a little
target practice behind my cabin
I just spend a lot of years shooting in
the Army just gotta kind of get the
feeling back in my hands
set my targets up it's time to kill them
got a 22 pistol
it's kind of my daily use weapon almost
always have it with me
that's the one I'll use for hunting
small game
anything from a squirrel to up to the
size of a beaver
locked and loaded
you see that Ricochet I don't see if I
can make it move
foreign
take a look at these ones real quick
this one I didn't hit
that one I didn't hit okay I need to
tighten up a little bit
the better shot I am the more
opportunities I have to eat good food
it's good for me to know how accurate I
am you know what I can expect to hit
I'm starting to get the feel of it
doesn't really matter if you can sit
there in AIM all day and get one perfect
shot usually it's more about getting a
quick shot I don't want to have like an
unrealistic confidence so it's more
about just kind of dialing those
reflexes in
that way I can go hunting with a little
more confidence
what are you gonna do just lay down and
quit and die in a lot of situations
that's what would happen if you just
gave up
just the constant living on the edge
tattooed on my arm it's it's what it's
all about
[Music]
yeah first sled run guys it's definitely
a big turning point in the season
with this lack of snow I got to make a
decision on the right to set a dogs to
take so that if we do have problems at
the creek crossings or if I'm going too
fast down the hills I have some control
Morello Captain I'm gonna run right
through everything out there on the
trail
all right guys who wants to go for a run
[Music]
the trail is really hilly it's a lot of
ups and downs and there's like three or
four creek crossings that can be a
problem
foreign
[Music]
ly thinking four or five steps ahead
down the trail we're so remote
there's not going to be any help out
there if you're on your own
everything goes silent
it's just you and the dogs and they're
doing their job working hard
it's my happy place
I'm kind of checked out away from normal
society and normal everyday nine to five
life
out here it just feels free
guys yep yep the real challenge is these
Switchback kills because I got eight
dogs that want to move forward and
they're pulling really really hard
with the snow machine you can do to hit
the brake and you stop
but with these guys you can hit the
brake all you want and sometimes you
can't stop
yeah they went to the Deep spot all
right all right good girls good boys
good dogs all right all right let's go
oh get out of hooked okay go go go
[Music]
we're a mile away
last stretch
looking at a Crossing like that with
deeper water and on ice shelf it's never
going to be just smooth sailing
there's a situation where the dogs are
better than the technology and the snow
machines way more reliable things go
sideways
I think we're pretty confident with our
abilities and so but I'm never really
worried about dogs they're pretty tough
in the end pretty much the human is
always the weakest link when it comes to
to being out on the trail
thank you
it's important now I feed the dogs and
give them a rest for a short period all
right oh right there here's one camp
that I set up earlier this fall for dog
mushing and it has a big tent that's
been around for a long time
well guys
it's like me lost our tent
this is a complete nightmare
back in civilized world there's so much
to worry about you got to make money you
got to go to town you got to battle
through traffic
out here we don't have any of that
you know I accidentally brought some
money out with me and it's crumpled up
in the corner of the cabin
it's just a better way of living out
here
I'm gonna go try to put my three wheeler
together get that going so I can get
some wood back to the house yeah I'd
love to fire up the stove and maybe make
some bread or
do some dishes that would be awesome we
need some wood all right wood is how we
do everything out here if I want to cook
I'm going to use my wood stove
if I want to heat the house that's fired
by wood if I want to shower that's fired
by wood
I've brought my three wheeler this
summer a strong background of mechanics
and the willingness to adapt and
overcome is really important out here
have to know your mechanics but you
really have to know how to fix things
with the wrong parts
you're never going to have the correct
tool or the correct part when you're
this far from town so making do with
what you got is something really
important
what my dad taught me to do was go to
the dumpster find a motor bring it home
and make it run with the parts you found
from the dump
I'm out here and I have to do that so
I'm really glad that he taught me that
as a kid
so now that I'm out at the cabin that's
pretty much all I do is fix junk with
other junk
can you come out for a minute
I can't start watch for a little blue
Spark
yeah it's definitely sparking I got that
starting floating I just try that
good afternoon I guess
[Music]
back in the city when you're doing
chores I always Grumble my wife's always
trying to get me to do things and I
don't want to or I do it half-assed but
out here I really want to strive for
excellence
and I get enjoyment out of all my chores
we got a lot out here do you think we'll
have enough wood here for the winter no
but this will get us a good start until
we get a lot of snow in and we can start
making trails
I've always tried to try to rely on
myself
I think it's just how I grew up
and out here it means a totally
different deal we don't have a hospital
or a doctor or a grocery store or a gas
station or even the internet so we have
to rely on each other
I don't know if I can haul this much but
I'm just gonna go okay just need you to
just push until I'm going and then I'm
just gone
the three-wheeler has already proved
itself it's pulling huge wood loads back
to the cabin that's really awesome
being out here is a lot of fun you're
totally reliant on yourself and in this
case my wife as well
we work as a team out here
being self-reliant it just feels good
and good work today you don't have
another Choice out here anyway so that's
what it is
so I'm a pretty stubborn person
it could be a good thing and a bad thing
kind of a double-edged sword
I think to live out here you have to be
pretty stubborn and bull headed
sometimes
just to get through you know tough
challenges
[Music]
this morning still hurting I'm still
pretty tired I haven't really recovered
from the previous days of work
my body is destroyed
right now
I gotta try to eat good you know if I
can get some rabbits that'd be great
so yeah fingers crossed I'm getting some
meat
so we're gonna go check my snares go
ahead and cut some wood while we're down
there
I'm gonna let sippy come today just
because no reason not to the snares are
a danger to them you know they're too
small you know he needs to get out and
have his fun too
[Music]
my other ones are somewhere right in
here
yeah everything's just as I left it so I
don't think anything's been through at
all
I would be lying if I said I wasn't a
little hopeful that there could be a
rabbit there but what would be ideal is
if like I saw that one of the snares has
been activated but at least that way I
know like okay they're coming through I
set my snare wrong so I think it's worth
leaving up as is and I'll go collect
some wood Tipsy hey this way come on
there was just a little squirrel barking
over there
I'm gonna see if I can get some lunch
where's it at huh
where'd he go
uh here's here's the nest you know
I just look for any kind of movement if
they jump from tree to tree then that's
easy way to catch them
we know he's here
that's why are you staying up high
squirrels tastes good it's just a lot of
work for a little bit of meat but it at
least provides good sustenance for the
day see if I can't get a little lucky
with my 22
foreign
the squirrels just move up real high the
tree and you just can't get them
yeah
I don't think we'll get this one
come on Bob
[Music]
I'm pretty knackered
it would be really nice to get some good
high quality game meat but it doesn't
come that easy no matter how tough you
are no matter how smart you are you're
really never completely in control so
you have to keep the faith and uh it's
gonna be interesting to see how much
endurance I have
if you want to live in the natural order
of the way of life you've got to accept
that the natural world might take you
I never know for sure what I'm gonna hit
but I wouldn't want it any other way
so I'm very pleased with how the
structure of the boat has cured zero
humidity in the air which makes the the
resin flow really nicely in the cloth
it's a really rewarding process seeing
this boat
prior to my work
after all this hard work laying up this
entire Hull it's time to break this
canoe from this two-piece mold
[Music]
got a really watch where you put your
hands with this stuff these slag ends
are as sharp as sharp teeth
so here's the moment of truth I'm
getting a workout
I am the quality control I am the
Craftsman I'm not trying to knock on
Engineers but I've seen things that were
designed with good intentions that just
work like crap in Alaska some of these
over-engineered things end up being
multi-million dollar mistakes spent by
agencies who have more funding than they
have common sense
foreign
there it is
boom
this 22 foot bear hole is looking
beautiful will look even better as I
trim all this sharp slag off the top of
the boat
[Music]
and each step of the process it'll get a
little bit cleaner a little bit more
finished and a little bit more refined
and then it's like my blank canvas I get
to paint it and just keep on with the
build
you know I like the sense of freedom of
not having somebody look over my back I
still have deadlines I still got to keep
that heating fuel in the tank to build
this 22-foot canoe and it's very
rewarding to see a finished product at
the end of the day and know that that
thing was built as best as I could do of
my own means I co-designed this bottle
cap with a local metal fabricator and
I'm very thrilled to be at this point
here you have undoubtedly America's
toughest canoe ever made and this thing
was designed and built by a mcmack
Indian Iraq war veteran moose hunter dog
musher me Michael Manzo this is my
indigenous belonging you know this is my
calling it's strong it's light
and it's fast for a canoe
this thing needs to get out the door it
needs to go do some work
doesn't it as like no other place on
Earth
there's a lot of train changes
there's a lot of temperature changes
everything's really difficult out here
when I'm back in the city I always
Grumble when I have to wake up at the
alarm I know I'm gonna have to do what
somebody else wants me to do
out here when the alarm clock goes off
I'm up on my feet
I'm splitting firewood I'm filtering
water
I'm getting things together I'm making a
life for my wife and I
check this out
that should cut through the ice I'd say
so
we have to have water for drinking and
cooking and laundry getting water is one
of the hardest Feats out here we have
really steep banks that are slick that
we have to cut steps into
if not we fall into the river one of the
first things I like to do today is get
the stairs put in they washed out since
we've been here last time we're a little
late to the season to be cutting steps
but we are blessed with a little rain
that softened up the ground so I was
able to cut those steps in but it's
still really difficult it's a nice step
good job I like it I like it
I like it a lot good for that Hill you
want another one no this is fine
now that we have snow and ice now it's
become kind of like a slide and if you
go in the river in Winter that's gonna
be a serious issue
oh
really afraid of falling in this water
down there it's really slushy today hey
Jess can you come Tie Me In
I've got to tie a rope on uh I can't be
falling in the water out here you have
to have a safety spotter because you
never know if you're going in the water
or getting hurt if I go in that's kind
of it if you go to the ice you're not
popping back up
you gotta chop through the ice as it
gets colder we're gonna get four and
five feet of ice out on the river
whether you're cooking or cleaning or
doing laundry that all involves water
which all has to be brought up from the
river that's a really difficult chore
but uh it's got to be done [ __ ] it
you're like right on the edge
man I don't like going down here
sure scares me
come on now
your scares me going down here
man I'm glad you're up there
it's kind of a long process
no one wants to go in that water
a couple days we're drinking
and cooking I finally feel like we're
settling in and I'm getting hang of the
work program out here hauling water
hauling wood working all day long till
dark and then working a little more but
that's what we signed up for we love it
out here what a great day photos
self-sufficiency building things making
things up
solving problems
I couldn't imagine a day that wasn't
like that
[Music]
hello guys
it's like we lost their 10. this is a
complete nightmare
all right time to go clean up the mess
from our tent collapse
look at the disaster Zone
yeah
there's no repair for this tent it is uh
goners
we just didn't get out there in time
after the first snowfall of the year
Salvage what I can luckily the cots and
the wood stove and a couple other
miscellaneous things were not damaged so
we were able to salvage that we recycle
everything out here nothing's ever
really truly garbage it's better to be
there and available than sitting in some
landfill lots of coals here lots of
stuff we can eventually make something
new with
and now I'm just gonna let this sit here
until it melts out and we'll rip it out
then because it's just totally frozen
down to the ground
looking forward to the hot spring soak
now that's the beautiful part about this
Camp even though the tent's bad there's
some hot water over there it's okay and
take a bath
so looking forward to that
done so poorly that I was just like a
screw Bush living I'm I'm done with that
you know I would say that's a failure
but as long as you're enjoying it enough
to keep going and you're winning right
[Music]
this morning I'm a bit tired doing the
kind of work I do without having like
meat and fat is really tough I'm also
feeling I'm dehydrated first order
business is I gotta get some water I
have to walk three miles pull it on a
sled by hand it's a long hike down there
to the spring always a chance to see
game so I always take my gun
your ego sips
to survive through winter Alex needs
fresh water but in order to get it he
must travel three miles by Snowshoe to a
local spring in harsh winter conditions
foreign
s you can get water
someone's done a big favor and put this
pipe in
I'll just make a little easier to get
I know this is clean because it's coming
straight out of the ground
a lot of the water that's coming from up
there it's got like a lot of iron and
stuff in it and algae and stuff growing
in it
this is definitely water to be savored
I'm gonna get 12 gallons I think that's
enough to last me for a while a couple
weeks at least
well that's not good looks like this got
some punctures in it it's gonna spill
you know half My Water by the time I get
back up to the cabin maybe there's
something I can stuff in there that
might help let me look around
birch bark is waterproof so try it
a corkscrew it in there and see it's a
Oddball solution
foreign
pretty clever about that
now the real uh struggle begins it's
probably 100 plus pounds of water
um just getting it moving is pretty
tough and I've got to keep this moving
generally uphill for a couple miles
it's very walking it's not like just
driving back to your house in your car
I'm pretty exhausted but I found that
you always want to be ready for the
unexpected he's over here
I hear flutter of the Wings
sips he's scared up a grouse
grass Tinder they try to hide and
camouflage
where's the s50 huh where's he at I
think he's somewhere in here sometimes
if you're quiet they'll make a little
little noise
I scared up a grouse
more in here
not bad
it's a nice little uh Spruce Grouse it
looks like I
got them clean through the heart yeah
this should make a pretty awesome dinner
tonight and uh thanks to my dog
come on tips
it's been another hard day of work but
today luck was on my side
this is my first successful hunt since
I've been up here it really energizes me
a lot it gives me a big boost of
motivation when we get back home we'll
have water in a nice little prize
being in the early winter there's one
River in particular in this region that
doesn't freeze it's fed by warm spring
water warm groundwater and I'm going to
take advantage of that and take out the
22-foot freighter canoe on this Clear
Water Creek oh she's looking proud out
floating good after long arduous hours
in the boat shop working late nights
now's a moment of truth
I'm going out and facing the unknown
because I've never run a river in the
middle of the winter but I'm right in
that wave of new and it feels great
22 foot long 60 inches wide
it's just a moose toboggan created we're
bouncing down rocky rivers with a boat
full of meat or fish
turned so nicely
and just smoothly running this River
Mack Indian canoe building is in my
blood you know it's a rewarding thing to
just reach back into the old ways of
things and make them radical for present
day
this Cadillac freighter canoe is
literally an extension of me
this is my violin
In this River
that's my stage
all right we'll give it a go
[Music]
save that for bait yeah thank you for
your life I was a little iffy because it
took a banging around getting up here
and that helicopter not my favorite
thing
this is what I've been waiting all year
for right cooking fresh caught food
catching this bourbon it was worth going
out one last time before we left wow
it's buttery and Flaky and sweet the
best dinner with the best person at the
best place I literally wouldn't change
this for anything
I've been wearing the same pair of long
underwear for six months and there's no
better bath than a pool of hot boiling
water in the middle of nowhere
[Music]
around here water is King having the hot
springs allows me to sort of combine a
whole bunch of stuff that I need to get
done like training dogs and checking out
the trail and checking the camp and
we're killing a whole bunch of birds
with one stone
[Music]
and getting that epic soak in too
[Music]
it's a nice fat male Grouse plenty of
meat I let sips eat most the organs they
will appreciate that
[Music]
it's snowing pretty good
before today I was feeling kind of like
I was deteriorating maybe it's just the
meat but today I feel the power
returning it's amazing how some small
successes can change your whole outlook
you did all the hard work
if you want to live in the natural order
of the way of life you've got to accept
that
the natural world might take you but you
just learn to get a little more
resourceful
I prefer to do things by myself being
more resilient and adaptable I think
that's a huge part of living in Alaska
is to be able to adapt to your
circumstances and your surroundings
me and the people that live like this
live the remote lifestyle far away from
town in society in the daily nine to
five grind every day just a little bit
of survival and I thrive on that
Alaska in the winter it's definitely not
really a place that's friendly to humans
but there's plenty of rewards to be had
you got to save room while you got them
that's the wishbone there
I'm wishing I get another one
because it's tasty
[Music]